these are calling the deaths of the 12th
wealthiest man in Canada and his wife
suspicious Barry Sherman he's chairman
of the pharmaceutical company Apotex was
found dead Friday Mr on toe area mansion
along with his wife her name was honey
the couple died from what investigators
described as ligature neck compression
police have not called their deaths
homicide Tony Jacopo's shows us why the
couple's loved ones are upset with how
police are reportedly handling this case
Tony good morning was a big shock a good
morning it's a sad end to a remarkable
life in many ways as you say Forbes
ranks Barry Sherman as the 12th richest
man in Canada with a net worth of 3
billion dollars he was also generous
giving away more than 50 million to
charity but because his company made
cheap generic drugs Sherman had plenty
of rivals Toronto homicide detectives
are now leading the investigation into
the deaths of Barry and honey Sherman a
police spokesman calls their deaths
suspicious after initially saying they
found no signs of forced entry and we're
not searching for suspects until we know
exactly how they died we treated as
suspicious and then once that once that
determination has been made by the
pathologist in the coroner then we move
forward from there The Globe and Mail
said the couple was found hanging from
the railing of their basement pool and
that investigators theorized the 75 year
old billionaire killed his wife and then
took his own life the family criticized
unnamed police sources saying in a
statement our parents shared an
enthusiasm for life totally inconsistent
with the rumors regrettably circulated
in the media where Apotex were in your
corner
Sherman's company and Apotex has annual
sales of over 1.5 billion dollars it
makes and exports generic versions of
brand-name medicines often putting him
at odds with other drug makers he fought
for what he really thought was right and
provide generic drugs that made it
possible for those that weren't on drug
plans to get the drugs that they need it
for the ailments that they suffered
service businessman Paul Godfrey and his
wife Gina were longtime friends of the
Sherman's it's just absolutely and God
smacked it says it's shocking and you
know it just leaves shivers all over you
a spokesman for the family tells CBS
News a memorial service is planned for
Thursday Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau offered his condolences on
Twitter saying Hina's wife Sophie are
saddened by news of the sudden passing
of berry and honey Sherman a mystery
it's a very remarkable life you know the
company started with two people now it
has 6,000 employees home that's a
success story Tony thank you so much